welcome I hope you thank you Anna yes
before I start my talk also a couple
organizational notes my personal thanks
to a porter for showing up at this last
second this is really very grateful for
this because we didn't want to lack
attention to Poland in this conference
so it will be a little bit different
than was to be presented but hopefully
it will elicit some interesting thoughts
in you and lead our discussion and I
also want to take this opportunity the
first time I've had a chance before a
microphone these days to thank the
organizations who helped organize this
conference that is the East Central
European center the Polish Cultural
Institute especially you dsg oh no and
the Ukrainian Museum where tonight's
concert will be taking place so on to my
paper
so so far at this conference does they
have managed to go to at least some of
the panel's you've seen that we've
reviewed the dissident movements in the
Soviet bloc and we've looked at how this
period is presently being researched by
scholars we've had a account of where
documents from this period are found
today what state they're in and I
thought it was really interesting we
actually got to see the documents
yesterday you know in very interesting
presentations and then yesterday in the
last panel we had the opportunity to
listen in on and participate in a
discussion between former Ukrainian
Polish and Russian dissidents now
finally this morning we were presented
with analysis of the legacy of the ideas
and achievements of these dissident
movements on the political situations in
the respective countries now in
establishing the scope of this
conference we also thought that analysis
of the nonconformist culture of the late
Soviet period and its impact today will
help us to compare these two periods and
these three nations in my presentation
today I will look at the impact of non
conformist late Soviet era ukrainian
culture on today's cultural activity in
ukraine specifically my talk will focus
on literature while occasionally
commenting on music as we see it tied in
with literature in these two periods the
purpose of my presentation which i've
titled
underground over time will be to
demonstrate what from this soviet period
came to be influential on today's
culture in ukraine to provide examples
of this influence in contemporary
ukrainian culture and to explain why the
influence of that nonconformist culture
continues to steer cultural developments
in post-soviet ukraine in addition to
providing my analysis our first part for
a brief historical background so that my
presentation could be valuable for
members of the audience less versed in
Ukrainian culture as is the nature when
you focus on three comparative aspects
so bear with me at the beginning
several sometimes overlapping
intellectual groups came to define the
post Stalin era in Ukrainian culture
among them were those who continued to
function as an instrument of the
Communist Party much in the same manner
as earlier while generally enjoying a
relatively freer intellectual atmosphere
of the thaw
we had dissidents who were politically
persecuted for their intellectual
activity and criticism of the government
a group that was politically and
socially engaged and we had marginalized
intellectuals who formed an unofficial
underground culture that would generate
a political and socially disengaged and
it is this third group that provided the
intellectual type with which the
post-soviet Ukrainian select role would
most closely identify the underground
unofficial cultural scenes that existed
in late so made Ukraine proved to be
very influential on the succeeding
generation of Ukrainian intellectuals
intellectuals from such movie was
different from the sixty writers this is
disapp Nakia in that they generally were
less publicly political than their
predecessors and were driven chiefly by
an interest in cultural developments in
a broader world that had been closed off
from the Soviet system they sought the
freedom to create outside the confines
of socialist realism and to acknowledge
the influence of previously prescribed
artistic achievements both Ukrainian and
non Ukrainian these artists rejected the
cult of the Soviet man and instead
stressed individualism in their art
analogous movements developed in other
parts of Soviet crane Moscow Leningrad
as we heard yesterday from Anne's
presentation and the Baltics in Ukraine
intellectuals involved in these
movements or sometimes the term they
seemed DC at may give the seventies
writers and the centers of their
unofficial culture were the cities of
cave and review the cave scene featured
several circles of individuals that
contribute to to alternative culture in
the Republic's capital in his article
alternative ookay V being alternative in
cave or alternative in cave Alexis I
mentioned Co lists
Bonjour doc let's put the V is key and
above all
des Brava as the leaders of the cultural
underground in cave earlier in the
second half of the 1960s a group of
poets known as caves gosh Korra the cave
school had formed in that city
consisting of a silly alla vodka Victor
Corden McCullough Vorobyov and the
kalahari this group often wrote in free
verse as part of a concerted effort to
reintroduce that poetic form which was
dismissed by Soviet culture policy as
being unearthed unartistic and even
subversive into Ukrainian literature and
as called them himself described it in a
essay the cave school of poetry can be
discussed in several aspects as a purely
poetic phenomenon that maintained free
creativity as its chief characteristics
as a group of young nonconformists who
designated free will in all of his
dimensions as their chosen path in life
as an experimental psychological attempt
as living at moving in a different
manner from other generations to live as
if your life were taking place in a free
and independent country as a brotherhood
of creators of poetry who held poetry
self as their main an extraordinary duty
James Scarola reacted to the Soviet
system and its restrictions on free
intellectual exchange by means of
exclusion denial and a hermetic escape
into poetry review also featured several
occasionally overlapping underground
cultural scenes the group that would
prove to be most influential on
subsequent generation of Ukrainian to
lectures was one that included an
equality of true Victor Morozov a local
shaman Keast Oresteia Dvorsky and
everybody to buy they would gather in
shahboz basement to read discuss an
exchange contraband literature share new
poems songs paintings which they had
created in his article symmetrical
singles are literature's role in Soviet
Ukrainian underground culture
quote it should be noted that under the
conditions of totalitarianism the best
way to be alternative was through
literature
whose creation requires only a pen and
paper and maybe a guitar and some vodka
Shabana scholar
just that they got all of the above
listed elements and in 1971 they
circulated a literary almanac entitled
skidding you the chest in Salvador
Sammy's doc format actually it's been
republished and
I had a copy of it
in addition to poetry prose written by
members that I had mentioned and shahboz
translation of today or salute averages
play funny old man the almanac featured
a questionnaire proposed by Roman keys
to members of this Brotherhood the
questionnaire which can be understood as
a manifesto of sorts warns of conformity
and uniformity and is primarily
concerned with existential issues and
the role of art and society listen God
was a contemporary writer who actually
was involved in republishing this he's a
publisher as well
he wrote that quote in his introduction
unlike the six years writers any belief
in the government had evaporated for the
seventies writers and they consciously
objected to tell Italian government of
course principles in literature and art
end quote select their counterparts in
cave these intellectuals were not
publicly political nonetheless these men
were Soviet outcasts who had been pegged
by authorities as being dangerous
they've been thrown out of higher
education system and they had
subsequently work at menial jobs thus
both in cave and the new view of
underground cultural groups of the 70s
featured intellectuals who existed on
the fringes of Soviet society showing
that space and occasionally crossing
paths with various other counter
cultural movements including a vibrant
hippie movement which one of our
colleagues Jim Murray bill Reese wah who
is monitoring next panel is publishing a
monograph where he covers that
extensively these intellectuals were
marginalized by Soviet society to a
position of eccentricity they were not
traversing the path that led to
advancement in the Soviet world in
society's eyes they were Outsiders
oddballs and derelicts and most
importantly they were different as
intellectuals who were Ukrainian who
resisted systematic versification and
identify with a Ukrainian culture that
was different than the sanctioned
restricted one of the Soviet world they
were seen as being especially subversive
they were prime candidates for what
contemporary writer Oksana's the
bush-gore refers to as quote all nine of
Dante's circles and quote that the
typical Ukraine intellectual of that era
had to pass through
unlike the six years writers many of
those whose
writings debuted in the Khrushchev thaw
relatively less restrictive at least we
thought so the 70s writers were from the
start subjected to the harsh crash downs
of crackdowns of the Brezhnev era during
which the dictates of socialist realism
were strictly enforced with no access to
official publications in which they
could publish their works the 70s
writers responded by writing for the
drawer and receding to an isolated
existence an existent that critical
asunder had a temper describes as quote
living under the snow besides shunning
the above-ground Soviet world for these
just mentioned reasons these individuals
hid from society due to a fear of
repression and a doubt and being able to
induce any change in the totalitarian
system witnessing the persecutions
suffered by the politically active
justice apnic your sixties writers only
cemented this attitude according to the
late salumi a Polish Co their
Hermeticism found a philosophical
grounding in quote Eastern philosophies
stressing the autonomy of the individual
of an identity separate from society
however it is within this underground
that these individuals were better able
to create a mirror society in which they
could coexist and maintain their
convictions artist studios cemeteries
and basements substituted for galleries
centre squares and theaters at which
creative works debuted and were
critiqued these underground cultural
communities and their activities became
legendary among other younger
nonconformist intellectuals who
themselves were then drawn into these
circles the result of such communities
was a synthesis of among individuals who
worked in various artistic genres as
I'll show you
writers visual artists musicians these
relationships were proved to be
important in the late 80s and early 90s
when this culture moved from the
underground entered the public sphere
they would provide a starting point for
the next generation of Ukrainian textual
is known as the recently south make it
this post-soviet generation
so now I will provide a few examples of
this influence as I promised and how it
came to be manifested in today's culture
the first is through the artistic genre
of some poetry one of these hybrid genre
as I mentioned it's an important medium
through which underground Soviet and
post-soviet culture became connected
undoubtedly influenced by the song
poetry of Polish bard just long Yemen
who wrote who would write songs and
poetry ignored even to his own words the
musician Viktor Morozov was sub music to
ukrainian poems the material that ranged
from the early poems of Parvati Chinna
- Ava citizen 1 M Capone to those of
morozov's good friend olala shahe and
later to those of a younger generation
of poets just as victory neva rock you
re under Kovac
Yvonne Malkovich more also scrapped
bridge these literary generations
combining them in a presentation of
authentic Ukrainian culture which
opposed the compromised false Ukrainian
culture erected by the Soviets and in
the past 20 years Morozov has further
extended this bridge by often
collaborating with the band metal
appealing that rooster whose members
were born just when this was being put
together in the early 70s 1971 Madonna
has served as a godfather for today's
musicians and many of his original songs
and his arrangements of folk songs from
various periods have recently been
covered by musical groups such as
because Katya and watch Jeremy the
latter group thought Jeremy is a band
that was formed and led by three.hoorah
Tobias santaros the rostra boy in fact
had been one of the founding members of
the Nezzer days don't worry cabaret
troupe in 1988 to go together with among
other his father's colleagues your even
the troop Victor Morozov and others
the popularity of nezhoda skyrocketed as
glasnost progressed their makes a
political and social satire and in
unearthing of unknown and previously
prohibited Ukrainian cultural
achievements in music and in literature
fed Ukrainians who were hungry for
something new and non or anti Soviet and
what was a very exciting time of change
Telos revised music has also been very
instrumental in another thing too
soviet underground culture of review
especially that the poetry of his father
who passed away in 1982 he has composed
recorded performed songs based almost on
all of his father's existing poems and
has organized massive concerts in the
country's largest halls to showcase his
father's poetry its culture by his
poetry was not published until 1990 it
was then republished in a 1998 volume
that includes essays by members of both
discourse to rise circle and younger
intellectuals on whom shibai was
influential I am sorry underground
culture was also influential through our
Ukraine in the 1990s and 2000's in what
is an especially vibrant example of
grassroots subversive culture becoming a
major cultural phenomena cassette tape
recordings of less Peruvian Suki's
reading of his own place particularly
his subversion of Hamlet were widely
circulated by Ukrainian youth in the
1990s and the plays themselves were
published in later in the volume hero of
our time in 2000 and the lavish CD said
then came out so it wasn't quite that
array but originally home tapes it was
quite interesting the poets of the
aforementioned cave school had become
legendary among young intellectuals and
later their poetic works became the
subject of analysis in literary journals
and actually in several dissertations I
know now written on this group in
Ukraine well they may be diplomas works
continue to be widely read and discussed
in Ukraine Ukraine's literary circles
his novel in the use kiwis entries way
won the BBC Ukrainian Book Prize for
2007 and his translations of dramas are
staged by contemporary ukrainian leading
troops today the brawl was relevant in
today's ukrainian culture is further
evidence when the influential literary
journal cut the fat it edited by 80's
whether unity was that it dedicated an
issue to him and his writing one last
specific example of the connection made
between underground culture of the 60s
and 70s and with post-soviet culture is
provided in the novel which hidden eMED
written by 80s writer question cinemas
Colette's that novel tells the story of
several members of livius bohemian scene
in
late 80s and early 90s it's also a
reflection of leave you in Ukraine and
how it kind of lost its center as a
place for artists in the early 90s but
what's interesting for us here is that
the way Moscow lets references the
poetry of Michael Arab shook in a novel
but if Chuck himself was one of the most
influential figures engaged with shaping
the face of Ukrainian literature in the
years surrounding the collapse of the
Soviet Union his apartment of view had
been a popular gathering place for
younger visual artists and writers in
the 70s and upon moving to Kiev and
establishing himself as a literary
critic the cuckoo is responsible for the
appearance of first publications for
several of today's leading writers
including other Hall which must
Colette's but is but it is his poetry
because he also wrote prose that most
Colette's directly references in the
2000 novel and that novel the narrative
occasionally becomes interrupted by
fragments of rebukes poems called from
the 1989 collections in Maui Wowi which
actually featured poems written much
earlier oftentimes these fragments
comment on a particular scene that's
unfolding in the novel the poetic
fragments served to add another point of
view to the novel and create a sense of
existence of a parallel world
Mosca lenses intertextual this direct in
textual connection with a of chook
serves to acknowledge the latter's
influence on his emergence as a writer
in that sense he constructs a direct
link between the eighties writers and
the underground generation that preceded
them the seventies writers and he finds
support in paralleling their existence
when which located it continues to
locate them mostly on the margins of
Ukrainian society and this is in
conclusion the means of creating and
developing a vibrant Ukrainian culture
independent of funding or government
support which was demonstrated by
underground Ukrainian culture of the 60
70s and 80s proved to be quite useful
example for cultural leaders in the
years since Ukraine achieved
independence the Ukrainian language and
culture today although free of the
restrictions imposed on the 60s and 70s
writers continues to exist mainly on the
March
of society the adsr managed to create a
culture scene that is varied and vibrant
and is making a name for Ukraine outside
the country but for the most part this
is not a culture that Ukrainian
politicians oligarchs media bang dates
or even official organs of Ukrainian
culture identified with thus they offer
no support for this culture and today's
cultural leaders are forced to resort to
grassroot tactics and support outside
the country just like their predecessors
in the 60s 70s 80s had to do in order to
continue advancing a Ukraine culture
that is intellectually and aesthetically
rich and of interest and critical
acclaim both inside and outside Ukraine
maintaining and expanding on connections
made with authentic Ukrainian and world
culture of the past and present forming
a community with others who exist on the
margins of society and using this common
other news to resist and critique the
center are all vital lessons learned by
today's cultural leaders from the
existence and the achievements of
nonconformist Ukrainian culture of the
1960s 70s and 80s Soviet Ukraine thank
you
our next speaker is between Yamanashi
she is an Whitney : professor and chair
of the planning department at Barnard
College and former director of the
Harmon teaster her books include Abrams
earth and the politics of crime
published by Yale University Press
in 1995 stroll with pushpins yeah
University Press 1993 under the sky of
my Africa Alexander Pushkin and
blackness not Western 200 6 and mapping
mapping the feminine Russian women and
cultural difference Slavica 200 8 she
established extensively on Soviet and
post-soviet literature and popular
culture and Pushkin also Russian ballet
and the future of Regina regional study
she is currently working on a book on
Nabokov and his enemies the terms of
engagement first of all I'd like to take
this opportunity because I'm not sure
there'll be another one to thank Marco
Andrade shik for the extraordinary work
he has done in putting together this
conference I'm also giving you great
papers
and I also want to thank Peter right
away for many things partially because
his books have been in my bookshelf
since college and he was he also helped
me set up my conclusion I have many
granted they go over many decades I mean
I like Marco I'm going to be talking
about literature exclusively although I
am very glad that we have been joined in
the audience by one of the foremost not
yes oh I'm sorry I was afraid that I was
gonna can you hear me
yes okay did you know what I said I
don't want to have to go back through it
again got me okay
I'm very glad that we have been enjoined
in the audience by a speaker from the
next panel one of the foremost
nonconformist art artists of the Soviet
and post-soviet period Vitali Kumar and
I hope it's Holi did some of the things
I have to say about literature might
resonate with what you have to say later
rather unexpectedly as a matter of fact
eschew surprise to me that I am able to
take as my point of departure and focus
for this paper
breaking news earlier this week the jury
for the nonce 1973 project awarded the
prize of the same name to Andres in your
skis strolls with Pushkin but I will
kiss Porsche King him which has been
described as by commentators as a
literate or they say a little literary
essay he won the prize of row daunting
field of competitors including Alexander
Solzhenitsyn School archipelago and
vairam column ops kolima tales this
event I will contend in my paper speaks
directly to the topic of this panel the
impact today of non conformist culture
and I'll say for those of you who are
not familiar with co-op skis work which
maybe many of you in this audience I
will say a few more words about it later
in the paper
sponsored by the Mikhail Prokhorov fund
um in conjunction assumedly with an L oh
no very literate or novice Rainier the
publishing and
prize of Prokhorov sister arena north
NOS which is perhaps also a slide link
at goggles nose is an acronym for Norway
sy vs lust which I believe in this
context might best be rendered as the
new bell let the annual prize first
awarded in 2009 aims as stated on the
Prokhorov fund website and I quote to
point out and support new trends in
contemporary artistic Bell letters in
the Russian language
end quote this year the north in the
prizes title might well have the
adjuster to nostalgia for North's 1973
turns the clock back 38 years placing in
contention works written or first
published in 1973 engaging in a
literature literary game due to the
toward Niagara which I take their
website to quote the poker of fun again
and I quote of course we are talking
precisely about a literary game and not
about the selection of a new Canon there
are enough hunters for a new Canon
without us as in the case of the debates
of lost 2009 and 2010 it is a game into
which we hope to draw the public in
order in particular to test which
versions of the alchemical union of the
aesthetic and the social resonate most
strongly with today's mindset with
today's experience both aesthetic and
social it goes without saying that the
naked attempt to rewrite history
imagining what a 38 year old shortlist
might look like if it were made up over
the barricades separating literature
that came out in Soviet editions in the
immigration and that appeared in the
underground is also a game and quote yet
this game at replaying history has a
serious point to use now acknowledged
classics as test models for
quote what after all we are seeking in
current fell left and code and again
what is being sought is of equally of
aesthetic and social value even allowing
for the adult of license taken by the
compilers of the shortlist for the prize
in assigning work specifically to the
year 1973 the richness of the yield and
the extraordinary conjunction of
literary talent is remarkable with very
few exceptions virtually every major
writer of the post Stalin period is
represented in the shortlist and some of
the most indisputably major works I'm
gonna give you the highlight well I'm
going to be the whole list actually I
think Alexander garlic general Mary
petits a general rehearsal when I did
your affair Moskva petrushka
vasily shukshin characters character II
of course addressing housekeeper group
is Pushkin installs of Pushkin
Ludmila petrol shaft Skye rocky Misaki
music lessons Fazil Iskandar Sandro is G
gamma Sandra French again Sasha circle
of solid rock off a scoffer fools
alexander solzhenitsyn
archipelago bog to go like archipelago
I'm a work by the branches through guide
the brothers regazzi brothers which I
don't know how its rendered in English
picnic now boy senior I work by Yuri
trifonov neutropenia impatience Vasily
accion of one of my personal favorite
works back son of Zola PI and nash's
Alaska my golden iron book and a work by
a New Guinea hairatan a frozen crows of
course varlaam Salamis
kolima tells and also work by Igor :
Rosa prose their works by her return of
and
: in particular the makers of the short
list pointed out they took a lot of
liberties they were written over the
course of a certain amount of time
there's clearly no easy answer as to why
the year 1973 produce such a literary
bumper crop
especially given the diversity of the
writers and the works from
Solzhenitsyn's monumental attempt at
literary investigation the Gulag
Archipelago to vintage of geography of
avant-garde called Cal classic mascota
to key to his gun there's magical
realist Sandro for chicken tuna Volkov's
perhaps in equal parts crotchety witty
and elegant collection of interviews
strong opinions which somehow got left
off my list but it's there
so Nabokov was there too in the context
of the very useful chronology of the
unfolding of distant activities and
crackdowns provided by Gerry labor
yesterday this richesse would seem to
appear counter intuitive indeed it might
be argued that the process of cultural
constriction the initiation of which is
most generally associated with the cine
op ski Danyelle trial in 1966 and it's
aftermath would seem to have reached
something of a head by the early 1970s
the majority of the writers on the North
1973 shortlist had been forced into
silence and or exiled by the year in
question
Nabokov a literary celebrity by that
time in the West was to all intents and
purposes a non-person in his homeland in
1973 it perhaps it was simply the case
that well into the second decade after
crucial secret speech had empowered
intellectuals to think of greater
freedom the seed sown in the wake of
Stalin's death had finally had time to
come to fruition the Chester de sac
Nicky had come of age at this point I
would like to bring together a number of
points that were made by speakers
yesterday for consideration for the
context of my future remarks an aprotic
expressed concern that referring to
dissidents in her term prisoners of
conscience as non conformist trivalent
trivializes their enterprise on the
other hand an komuro me flag the element
of playfulness in the dissident text
which he associated largely with
Leningrad as a
to the more serious Moscow and Pahlavi
tniv pointed out that the very term
dissident itself had actually originated
in the West and was not a self
description I put these points together
here because I think they captured
tensions latent and sometimes not so
latent especially after many dissidents
found themselves in bitter factional
contention in emigration tensions latent
and the dissident movement itself and I
think that the results of the North's
1973 prize may help us to understand the
legacy and impact of the historical
interplay between non-conformism and
dissidents
in Russian literature and culture today
to clarify my point here let me focus on
the NOS 1973 winner for a moment in
quotation marks strolls with Pushkin in
the context both of other works on the
short list and of the history of its own
Genesis and reception and here one
little digression I would like to note
that in this regard that I happen to be
staying in the for the past two weeks
before this conference in a single ski
house in Fontana Oh close outside of
Paris where that other legendarily
outspoken figure of the dissident
movement who has not has yet to be
mentioned by name at this conference
sanyaas Keyes Widow Mario Rosa Nova
still presides writing her memoirs which
is something for the Nathans and all of
us to look forward to it when they
appear and I am therefore pleased to be
able to cite a number of her anecdotes
in what follows I've already written a
lot about the scandals attendant on the
reception of strolls of Pushkin first in
the emigres community in the West when
it appeared in 1973 in Russian and then
among the Rousseff Feldkamp
of the Soviet Writers Union when it or
actually only a small fragment four
pages of it appeared in the journal ox
yeah but in 1990 during glass
as a maverick you know to bring a little
Russian Institute and Columbia history
in here
I first met Sanyasi downstairs in this
building in 1978 when he gave a lecture
which into a crammed auditorium I think
there are at least 300 people there all
waiting for a scandal from Abraham
carrots and who in fact showed up at the
stade professor Andres in yarski who
gave a very very solid scholarly lecture
on why the memoirs of the arch priest a
become more properly belonged to modern
Russian literature than to old Russian
literature so it was an interesting
question period afterwards but somewhat
more lively because strolls was Pushkin
and a number of other things came up but
what I don't know how many of you in the
audience may remember this there was a
woman of shall we say a certain age who
was picketing back and forth between the
main gates of the Columbia of Columbia
with a sign that said Steve is from
comrade of ROM
shame to you comrade you know which was
apparently a protest against rosal
Pushkin so there's a history here as far
as the scandals go I will merely remind
you that readers as diverse is the first
way the emigres Rahman Gould the
dissident writer guild give lady mo the
conservative Pushkin is valentina for me
she who is no relative of mine no matter
what you've heard and the rusev feel
dissident eager these were josephovich
found provocative metaphors out of which
the fabric of strolls with Pushkin is
woven metaphors like Pushkin ran into
high poetry on an erotic legs and
created a sensation or emptiness is
Pushkin's content or that really really
really can't reverse all comparison of
Pushkin with a vampire they found these
kind of these metaphors to be at best
they'll considered and at worst
dangerous russophobic attacks on Pushkin
as an icon of
Russian culture for those of you who do
not know the work first of all rush
right out and buy it and read it and but
I would also say that it is a dazzling
text made up completely of metaphor
after metaphor which I have been told by
a number of younger generation Russians
reconciled them to Pushkin after he had
been deadened for them by the Soviet and
post-soviet school curriculum perhaps
more to my point here Alexander
Solzhenitsyn and what was at the time
his only literary critical essay which
took its title from Pushkin text devoted
solely to an analysis of strolls of
Pushkin recognized the talent of the
work but found its emptiness its lack of
a clear religious Underhill
philosophical points of point of great
concern more disturbingly Solzhenitsyn
who was at that time writing in
emigration ended his article on strolls
with Pushkin by in essence calling for
censorship because he felt that writers
like Shenyang ski I taken the freedom of
speech given to them by immigration in
the West to make they may have been
irresponsible in their use of this
freedom and had placed Russian culture
in jeopardy for me this is indeed the
point where playful in quotation marks
non-conformism and serious in quotation
marks dissidents part ways in order to
pursue this point further this rift
between what I would term the two
tendencies in Russian cultural
resistance let me point out that
sannyasi himself was always
uncomfortable with the term dissident
they're coming to me I'm sorry I'm okay
sorry okay I'm very sorry okay well
there you have text later okay I'm
usually not hard to hear okay I was
trying not to drown you out okay in
order to pursue this point further this
rift between what I returned the two
tendencies in Russian cultural
resistance let me point out that son
asking himself was always uncomfortable
with the term dissident he always
insisted that he had essentially ceased
karazna glass with the Soviet regime
stylistic disagreements with the Soviet
regime no no to my mind his most
eloquent statement in this regard came
during his quote of his closing speech
at his 1966 trial referring to his
wonderful story defense space in history
finds himself trapped in a human body in
the Soviet Union and forced to hide his
true identity
Sanyasi said and I quote an again this
is from the closing speech at his trial
in my unpublished story hence there's a
sentence that I consider
autobiographical you think that if I am
simply different - boy you must
immediately curse me so there it is I am
different do goy but I do not regard
myself as an enemy and my works are not
hostile works it was it mentioned at
some point in the last two days in in
this conference that tsunami was tried
for political writings but the fantastic
fictions that constituted the basis of
the charges for which sanaka was sent
into hard labor any political on their
most superficial level more upsetting
and to the soviet authorities
I believe was the fact that senior ski
to ski starett's walks elude
classification as much as they eluded
the control of sensors that they broke
stylistic rules and were playful in that
sense in this context it seems that the
fact that the KGB and single skis French
publisher misconstrued the nature of
straws were Pushkin in exactly the same
way
and moreover we're the same mistake as
did the sensors at du bateau vlog the
playhead labor camp where Sinofsky was
incarcerated while he was writing
strolls in letters to his wife
he's very telling mothers know that as
many times over many years contended
with some grave that she brokered her
family's release from the USSR by
threatening the KGB with the fact in the
camps and that the manuscript of the
work was already in the rest to be
published if anything were to happen to
him imagined the contents of the labor
camp
to be by the center can once the Nazca
was in the West
his French publisher scooped up strands
will push pin a pair away on the same
assumption that he was acquiring the
juicy potentially best-selling labor
camp expose actually after signing the
contract it is all about on the other
hand when I was asked on today's are not
image so yeah why was that the camp
censors did not get suspicious that he
was writing so much about Pushkin in his
letters to his wife
all they cared about was that he was not
complaining about the food all the other
rigors of camp life how could they have
known that some mouse key was writing
out in letters what would be one of the
most scandalous books on this time
period and for those of you who don't
remember this kind of I will simply
mention the fact that he actually I was
compared to Salman Rushdie and those who
did that actually reciting with the
Ayatollah how many and suggesting that
the death threats against Allah and rest
assured cracks will also be leveled
against new offski for writing this work
that was much later play the part of a
very serious sort yesterday Ben Athens
showed us a document from senior skis
KGB father which there's evidence of
sophisticated technical analysis of the
typewriter used to produce the touts
works those of you who brought his
extraordinary autobiographical in quotes
in quotes off his list of memoirs lately
goodnight skis patrol of the
cat-and-mouse game
detective plot in which the criminals
control over are the good cars a section
of the novel in which he says authorizes
precisely the search for Abrams Harris's
true identity by seeking the
characteristics of the criminals
typewriter which keys you know could you
find the actual identity of the
perpetrator
I see the peculiarities of Hope that on
which the works were tight is made work
seores keys unknown of a strategy to
elude the authorities may have
a game or at least they saw it as a game
just as playful just as play the playful
text of strolls of Pushkin aimed to
liberate Pushkin from the deadening of
conformity of conventional survey
Pushkin studies which supported Pushkin
to ideological aims but these games
again were serious they were games so to
speak to the death soon asking knew that
the game of Abrams health would end in
the labor camps and for those of you who
did not know him or did not know this
Sandow ski honestly did not believe that
he would survive his sentence
let me repeat this play was serious
indeed so back to the present we first
learned we meaning those of us who were
gathered including Julie Danielle
stepson in Paris last week that's Joseph
Pushkin was on the shortlist for lost
1973 from in articles whose author
assumed that the prize would be taken by
one of the elephants in the short list
that is social needs since Gulag
Archipelago or shalom ops Kalima tells
that is the serious works and it must
admit that we are including senior ski
zone writers son who himself has earned
quite a reputation as a writer in French
we are inclined to agree so when the
word came through on Wednesday morning
so you can tell not long I have had to
write this paper without straws with
Pushkin had one it was something of a
shock and a vindication now in the
interest of full disclosure I should
note at this point that it was not a
clear land in fact there were four
winners stroszek Pushkin took the prize
as the selection of the jury in a tie
broken by the decision of the head of
the jury however the choice of experts
there's more
Institute of thank you very much to
Marco for the kind invitation I beg your
indulgence in advance because this is a
fairly non-standard presentation
certainly the first time I've done
something like this which is that I got
a phone call at 10:00 p.m. yesterday
from Houston abena who fell ill and was
unable to come and this morning she
emailed me sketches for her presentation
so I have the task of basically giving
you a two-for-one deal today which is to
offer
her presentation in rapid as to the
extent that I can and then to sort of
riff in another direction on the same
theme her presentation or such as it is
for the moment is dealing with the
impact of non-conformism and dissent in
film in Poland since 1989 and I will
take that as a point of departure for
some comments on the history of the
cultural significance of the history of
commemoration of Captain in Poland
particularly in reference to Angela via
this film so the answer to the very
interesting question imposed by this
conference is there a lasting and
currently relevant legacy to the culture
of nonconformist men dissent that
flourished in Poland during the last two
decades of the communist rule very much
depends on whether we focus on the
former more general or latter nor
Spaceship temporally specific part of
the question as long as we remain in the
sphere of the idea of descent and
counter culture we can clearly see that
such discursive spaces exist today even
if we limit ourselves to consider only
one space of culture film just as they
did 25 years ago even if they have been
around different issues today those
issues are for example women LGBT
community rights to be even more
specific quotas that would guarantee
women's political representation the
debate over in vitro fertilization
legalization of gay marriages
environmental issues including resource
management urban planning etc as opposed
to the concerns of the 1970s and 1980s
which included for example freedom of
expression workers rights and workers
unions or low pay versus rising prices
of basic foodstuffs the difficulty in
tracing the link between the forms of
dissent practiced by poland's opposition
and counterculture in the 1970s and
1980s and those practice today lies in
the fact that not only both the foci of
interest and the forms have drastically
changed forms have changed in response
to the degree of granted freedoms in
press for instance but also in response
to changing technologies that allow for
computer-assisted
cent for example YouTube among other
things social networks constructed
online but also in that today's
dissenters do not necessarily inscribe
themselves in the great tradition of the
Committee of the defense for workers and
solidarity there is perhaps very little
living memory
in fact of descent of the two pre 1989
decades or very little or no interest in
positioning oneself particularly among
younger generations as a direct
beneficiary of the tradition that was
able to dismantle an empire change the
whole world's balance of power and
affect the lives of millions of people
to sum up the ideas of non-conformism
descent seem to be permanently inscribed
tattooed if you will on polish culture
going back at least into the 19th
century romantic messianic ideologies
which translated the forging of national
identity into seeking ways of attaining
political independence and to promoting
a clandestine model of culture that make
the national project possible
encouraging underground activities
defying authorities inventing or
perfecting various forms of explicit and
implicit protest eg through religious or
literary practices etc however if we
talk about the more historically
specific tradition of dissent such as
the Polish opposition of the 1970s and
1980s that led to the creation of
solidarity in August of 1980 which
served as a social and political
platform for counteracting the effects
of martial law in the early 1980s and
orchestrated the fall of communism in
1989 the question of guiding legacy or
passing memory becomes more complex it
becomes even more complex if we narrow
down our field of vision to literature
culture and the arts ie the contemporary
aesthetic representations of ideas of
dissent or opposition as developed by
Polish dissidents between 1970 and 1989
approximately now this was intended to
be one of two substantive sections of
Houston as presentation and it is
somewhat incomplete so the way that I'm
going to frame the just does it just
introduce the fragment that I'm reading
is with an empty emphasis was originally
supposed to combine litter
aesthetic sculptural representations and
film and in the end there will be a
couple of references to the other media
but the focus in the comments that I'm
going to read is on film there's anyone
here who might wonder why pigs nails and
Lego blocks all of these in quotation
marks are brought up at this point let
me briefly explain that these are three
canonical in the sense of belonging to
the Canon of transgression products of
post-communist polish culture pigs being
the title in translation of what this
what peshkov sqeeze coke movie entitled
pigs the original polish being saved
produced in 1991 and dubbed poland's
first blockbuster film nails IE and j
nails para Bukowski
being the drug-dealing narrator and
protagonist of Dora Thomas Wolfe's cos
2002 novel Snow White Russian read in
the Polish original Varna postcode
escape would flag on yellow to Devon all
described by critics is iconoclastic
provocative and almost blasphemous
and finally Lego blocks being the
primary material used in the so called
lego concentration camp set an equally
heretic or conceptual work of art
designed by his being in free bed on in
1996 what these and other projects of
this kind have in common is that they
constitute quote art of insult unquote
to use Alan Cooper means app term from a
Washington Post article discussing the
bettas conceptual art the question is of
course water who is being insulted
most likely does the romantic paradigm
to use polish Larry critic Mario union's
term for Polish cultures romance with a
quote unified romantic symbolic style of
culture
end quote fueled by the Romantic period
with its polish flavor messianism Pollan
seen as a Christ of Nations tropes of
Makka pakka
polish mother Makka pakka mother Poland
to mention just a few phenomena going to
this paradigm the Romantic Age did not
really end until 1989 and while it
lasted as beyond Yun argued it served a
compensatory therapeutic function for
the nation as a legitimate Enya writes
quote this all-embracing paradigm
designated a very clear
for art and the artists throughout most
of the past two centuries polish art was
expected in condition to perform service
on behalf of the captive nation end
quote
Metheny a-- proposes to call this state
of affairs a salvation or culturalism
after a Juniper dude I'm the sole role
of which is to mobilize culture in the
service of Polish national politics as
the key elements of the culturalist
syndrome she sees recounting of heroic
past as a prime builder of national
consciousness the idea of a tortured
nation heavily gendered and in the
absence of a satisfying reality a life
within symbols and allegories community
of the spirit the absence of a
satisfying reality any effort to
challenge polish culturalism has been
and still is a controversial if not
indeed sacrilegious undertaken efforts
to contest the legitimizing power of
time have been consistently defeated
because they competed with a key
priority the project of national
sovereignty the pervasiveness of
spiritual suffering mixed with messianic
fervour and popular religiosity were all
products of the romantic outlook and a
bold move to expose this culturalism
spent force made a relevant after
reaching the ultimate liberation in 1989
literature film and art initiated a
shift from the symbolic spiritual realm
to the physical sensual emphasis from
the intuitive passionate to the rational
discursive this move away from romantic
fixation on the soul brought about
various transgressions artistic artists
proposed new explorations of history
particularly is beaten every bad arm of
patriotism and Poland's entrapment
between east and west but also
explorations of the body within its
physiology of polluting successful
cultural models such as polish cinema of
moral concern from the 1970s and 80s
which vytas men of marble is a prime
example as our films by Agnieszka
Holland Christophe kievsky artist of
Zanussi with new polish films with
American accents such as gender
destabilization and control and
construction transgressive art objects
of which I gave only brief examples
expand may we say the shrinking public
sphere which is as yogin hubba masa
stated a sphere of criticism of public
authority created by private agents ie
civil
the works I mentioned here challenge the
core traditions of artistic
representations such as such perhaps but
even more so they question the polish
artistic canon for its devotion to the
national community they question the
easy marketability of patriotism as a
commodity and also question the role of
the writer filmmaker artist who has been
seen as a spiritual leader providing a
needed sense of group identity in
solidarity with in the romantic paradigm
the new artists are create spaces of
dissent art becomes a realm in which
democracy is being tested art has have
become a strategy for expanding
dimensions of democracy for pluralizing
the public sphere in order to engender
citizens deliberations and negotiate
differences this transgressive art while
often jarring and uncomfortable to read
watch or process otherwise allows for
periodical revivals of the discursive
aspect of civil society and a broadening
of its public spheres my students can
attest how uncomfortable the
transgressive work can be by saying
about the film pigs it's not a good film
but it's very interesting in that sense
transgressive novels films and
installations serve as props in the
process of civil disobedience 1989 was
an obvious scissor and the development
of Polish cinema Marek heart of called
the situation after 1989 landscape after
battle in the summer of 1989 a peaceful
transition democracy was made following
June first free elections and the
formation of the first free government
headed by today's massive it's key 89
was likewise a turning point for the
Polish film industry once again it was
not a cinematic movement but a political
transformation that defined a new period
the nationalized and centralized film
industry entirely dependent on
government funding was transformed into
a free market economy subsidized by the
state filmmakers were relieved of their
traditional duties as a conscience of
nation liberated from political
commitments the political role commonly
reserved for artists has returned to
politicians and filmmaking has become a
professional eyes endeavor after 1989
many films that were shelved by
censorship were released including
Crystal Cave skis blank chants Agnieszka
Holland's a lonely woman bogus Keys
interrogation the move toward market
economy coincided with the
universalization of co-productions in
Europe and
incorporation of American popular cinema
into the market the end of communism and
the emergence of a new audience have
brought some inevitable changes to film
production and distribution as well as
to film fanatics in stylistics
co-productions multinational enterprises
connections with Hollywood a plurality
of styles and genres have been changing
the film landscape in Poland after 1989
there were claims supported by Viva
solution Holland that the Polish cinema
was in danger of extreme
commercialization some filmmakers went
as far as to say that state censorship
ensured artistic originality Keselowski
remarked that filmmakers were in Poland
in a quote luxurious and unique
situation we were truly important
precisely because of censorship
now we're allowed to say everything but
people stopped caring what we are
allowed to say and this is where the
passage that I have from the intended
speaker for today stops my own the
connection that I thought useful to make
when I was just in my brief reflections
that I've had the opportunity to put
together on the topic of the conference
it seems to me that the notion of a
guiding legacy or passing memory forces
certain questions to be asked in terms
of what specific notion of culture is
being deployed now I don't really
specialize in literary analysis or an
aesthetic analysis as such but I have
had a secondary or even tertiary
interest for some years in the
commemorative movements of the coupling
massacres of 1940 and I couldn't help
but notice when I was in Poland for the
release of an joyriders film cotton in
2007 that the event itself brought
opened a media a media storm opened a
storm of public discourse all the
elements that use thinner describes as
being problematized once again in the
context of a post 1989 public sphere
come into play with the film cotton in
2007 and three or four years later now
we can also see deeper much deeper
problematization of the issues create
open by the
in the context of the plane crash the
presidential plane crash last year which
opens up the issue of whether or not
there is a cutting number two so the
cutting public debates generated in
Poland combined to a certain extent a
mediatized version of the 1940 massacres
with this politicized also media ties
been a completely different fashion
symbolic notion of a cutting number two
emblem a' ties in part by a cross
planted in front of the presidential
palace initially as a symbol of mourning
and subsequently devolved into a
confrontation between certain fringe
groups both secular and and and
religious mmm i don't really have an
opportunity to launch into any kind of
even remotely sub full-throated analysis
of of the issues but one thing that i
did want to underscore is that we're
talking about legacy and memory notion
that's that i i've associated with this
sort of debate having attended several
conferences and having organized one
myself on the collapse of communism
several years ago is the notion of
ghosts if you're familiar with alexander
atkins work on russian literature
post transition post transformation
ghosts and demons and spirits and
phantasms inhabiting and personifying
unprocessed on work through in the
benyamin ian sense elements of
transition from communism to post
communism and this is something that I
think is interesting to throw into the
discussion also of the coupling film now
again I forgive me please for not being
able to go into more detailed analysis
but I will raise the point that I'm je
Vida is an element of what what has been
called post memory in the sense that he
is the son of a victim of one of the
massacres that are collectively grouped
into the counting massacres he's the son
of a victim who died at how chief at the
hands of the NKVD in the spring of 1940
and if you look at his his public
statements upon the release of the film
or in the debates particularly let's say
following this malaise plane crash
there's a deep person
connection that embodies I think a lot
of elements that it would be hard to
chalk up to the type of discussion of
culture that we've been having so far in
this session today but I think our
nonetheless worthy of emphasis which is
a more problematic boundary between
popular and elite culture in other words
the victims destined for killing by the
nkvd in the capting massacres were
designated as such because they were
personified as elites the bourgeois
counter-revolutionary elites and yet
there has been a trouble can significant
trouble since 1989 in Poland with
establishing the line and establishing
an audience for popular representations
of histories of the cutting massacres
and commemorations of the cutting
massacres because of this line to what
extent is it possible for families of
these ideologically designated elites
who were bracketed in this group for the
duration of the People's Republic of
Poland and yet to what extent can that
be communicated to a broader public and
be entrenched as a core element of
national culture and certainly the VISAA
film and certainly the smoke of the
plain presidential plane crash last year
have changed the valence of those
debates but if you examine more closely
the history of commemoration practices
of cutting itself which involves a
history dating back into Sabrosa
conversations in the late 1940s and
throughout the 1950s among family
members post 1956 actual kamal scale
commemorative ceremonies held first for
example in 1959 at the provence key
military cemetery in warsaw very
interesting documentation in the state
security archives in poland on this for
example just initially talking about
lunatics from older generations who are
going and needn't be troubled because
their activities are not politically
relevant then emerging over the course
of the next two decades into a deeply
deeply salient element of the
clandestine activities so in the cutting
institute or the cutting committee
created in the late 1970s that were
subsumed into the Solidarity movement in
1980-81 this is all reflective of what's
curious a major movement that had a lot
of trouble creating
mainstream visibility for itself as a
movement independently of any political
messages until by this film came onto
the picture I don't want to go on
because I think I'm already over time
for the collective reflections of
Houston and myself and I don't want to
suggest that I've by any stretch of the
imagination can cover all of her
material in Q&A but the general
arguments in specifics as well thank you
very much and I have to say
yes
before sanyaas he was responding very
explicitly and I had the opportunity to
talk to him about this over the years he
was political only in the sense that he
wanted to respond to the survey
state's position that anything was
political and by reclaiming a sphere for
something that wasn't political but it
but if you accept that that was a
political act you are accepting
precisely the terms that the Soviet
government was imposing upon culture
that's all
thank you do you respond uh I guess what
were two questions to me at the end I
don't think there's any doubt that the
circles that I talked about would
exclude Lena kostenko from authentic
Ukrainian culture or from or worse we
ditched me for that matter and so yes
that's part of the connection made going
back to the 20s and and I also I
mentioned that that would be one of the
reasons why you would go underground was
because of what they witnessed happening
to to address this a little hard the
remarks of you steena
particularly on the romanticism issue
and polish culture before 1989 I know
this is a commonplace of this romantic
tradition yet I in reality I wonder a
sort of national obligation and other
things I can see in this but is this
really all as related to a Polish
romantic tradition as as many would
affirm then on sensibilities one of the
things that I wish we had had yesterday
I said I wish we had Lithuania today I
wish we had the Czech Republic that is
we could have addressed Czech culture
which I think would have been essential
for when we talk about how now people
after 1989 91 relate to the culture this
this as far as I can see probably the
easiest connection is with much of the
Czech writing and maybe address that how
that relates in comparison to polish
then on the question of censorship
I always think one of the greatest gifts
the Soviets gave
Polish cultures they stop the filming
about nummy Nachum because then when of
course you could think that this great
film would come and then of course
somebody had to create the film and then
the film became a politically correct
cowboys and Indians film that really so
as a film that was not filmed it could
be a great film in Polish tradition as
soon as you film that you were stuck
with it but this relates to the
censorship issue that everyone everyone
faced and this is my more general
question to all and the heart I know to
give an evaluation in evaluating the
culture of the this 1960s to 80s and
what remains and we all know how we
react
young but many of us reacted to this as
it came out in a specific context our
evaluation of this culture was related
to that context and the conditions under
which people created symonenko as a poet
or the letter to the Kurds these things
that were so meaningful to us at that
time I wonder in all three cases of the
speakers now I realize there's very
large topic who would say that if they
were addressing their classes and saying
okay this is really what still you would
look at at this period and I can
recommend to you and it doesn't make any
difference that you haven't got the
faintest idea in what conditions this
arose and what the conditions were what
do you think of it
I think I can answer that question in
the following manner there was a recent
publication edited by voca me libera
host go boom poke Alenia it's a series
of interviews with she's desatting icky
and once in this ethnic and an
introduction she refers to the legacy of
the sister sotnik here and I actually
had it and I think I have it quoted here
but maybe not but in general the idea
was that it's more of an historical than
a historical legacy then a cultural
legacy or
was quoted I have it here somewhere but
she had it as part of that and I think I
think that is what I feel about it to
that yes I would teach my students of
course but out of context it may not
have the same resonance and may not have
the same influence as other works from
the period but quite important of course
seniority has a gray line sorry well
actually since he's the subject of my
talk in my paper I guess I shouldn't be
sorry to keep bringing him up
someone says censorship was the best
friend of the Russian writer because it
you know if you were some British Lord
who thought you had great talent as a as
a poetry and do something useful with
your life
you could just claim that you know
because they were brave of the cab
experience I think it will be back up
during the list well I think there were
there were several questions
specifically address teas than that
right so for a moment my sense now
obviously this is only a fragmentary
analysis and I think I'm afraid that
ultimately we don't really get Houston
as own analysis in here because the
point of departure is that examples from
the aesthetic field such as masuka's
writing such as Pesci Cove Sookie's
filmmaking address the standard
perception which is also what you're the
object of your objection it's I think
right so you know I obviously agree that
there's far more than just the National
Martyrology and I think you've seen a
would as well so I think also if you go
I don't want to make Mario Yan Yan and I
just be at the methania and these other
sort of analysts come out I don't want
to make them sound like I don't want to
reduce them to sort of a broad sense of
Longy of a nationalism and messianism
because I don't think that's quite their
point either I mean my sense is the
point here is that the aura that is
defined by the reaction immediately post
1989 as all of these analysts perceive
it is the aura of Romanticism as it
existed before so it's a return to
whatever was before communism in some
cases it's a return to before 1918 in
particular I don't want to go into too
much detail because it isn't really my
field but I mean week there I I could
give you several examples off the top of
my head from the communist period
depending how you define obviously
and intellectual activity that show that
there's far more going on but that is
your point as well so yes you're right I
think the point is well taken I think
you still I would say the same in terms
of sensors but the Czech culture issue I
didn't quite get from your question did
you think that Czech culture would be a
point of contrast or a point of
confluence my cursory impressionistic
answer would be yes although I think
that the EBI essence if we're going
again from Euston is framework to answer
your question it's less about the
literature itself than about the canons
that have been defined since 1989 to
capture what was going on immediately
before 1989 which unfortunately I don't
know well enough to be able to answer
the question Georgia College to general
questions
- honestly I mean a pillar if you'd like
to answer that's fine - I didn't know if
you wanted that's a question that just
responses to that what constitutes
cultural authenticity and second this
regards art and aesthetics and that is
the violation of literary and artistic
form become political because that does
have implications I think definitely for
the late Soviet period for both of our
presenters today I'm not sure I
understand how are you the first
question because I can think of a number
of different ways of answering it but I
don't have
like they're not what you're asking okay
okay then you did then you do that yes I
mean I I would only throw out is that
the first thing they came into my head
was that in the preface the Gulag
Archipelago Solzhenitsyn claims absolute
authenticity for his work of literature
because he has carried out the
experience upon which it is based on the
marks on his body that were left by the
camp you know so that's a kind of but
I'm not sure that that's what she meant
okay the second question the second
question was because I did have
something to say about that
I think that that in in a Soviet period
that was a major major issue and this is
this is one of the topics that I think
is is it is a happening topic right now
that that as we get some distance from
the period we find that you know that
old that old chestnut that you know
people got shot for in the 1930s that
you were formalist was more than just an
empty political slogan that that
conforming to rules about how you
presented art in all across across the
spectrum of the Arts was the key the key
the key characteristic of socialism what
I tend to say to my students is that for
instance you can make a lot of you can
do a lot of similarities between Norman
Rockwell and socialist realism in fact
there are some there's some evidence
that socialism was influenced by Norman
Rockwell if you like Norman Rockwell you
could buy Jackson Pollock you know I
mean you had a lot of choice in the
Soviet Union that wasn't true there was
one acceptable style and so it was the
confirmative style and so when you start
getting into the into the post on was
the the avant-garde artists just as
props in the 20s that
and this is why I don't think soon
asking was ever playing games about
saying he had stylistic disagreements
that that really was there really isn't
anything terribly politically
questionable about his works on the
other hand so eager to welcome social
needs him back because I'm in some ways
the form of his works the way he wrote
the basic understanding of the
relationship between language and
literature that souls Newton accepted
was identical to socialist realism and
again I read a good part of my doctoral
dissertation and my master's thesis on
Solzhenitsyn so as much as I'm taking a
certain stance here I I don't want to
suggest that I don't think he was a
talented writer but he was published he
said and you know you know it's it's not
about really you know the rules so much
it's about there's only being one set of
rules I mean one of 20th century's
greatest ukrainian poets Mikkola is out
of wrote in a form that was all about
you know writing the perfect sonnet and
it was all about keeping to the rules
and can you do the perfect things so it
wasn't about that it's just about being
one set of rules and the linking I mean
this is a term I use so it's first that
I answered this authentic court I see as
a linking to previous cultural
achievements that had been banned or
suppressed and this needs to connect
this to counter what was being presented
as you know the Soviet Ukrainian culture
so in this sense it's authentic yes this
is Ukrainian culture this is what we
this the tradition we come from these
are our influences we are part of this
there is a linking to this and that's
what I meant by that term bill if that's
helpful
situations the future in the present
production production I'm willing to
take this on because I think it again it
was something I was trying to suggest at
the end and something in an earlier
version before Cindy asked you won this
prize I had different paper you know
that it's one thing to talk about
non-conformism in a society I think my
opening line was we can argue about
whether the Soviet units totalitarian or
not but we can't really argue about
whether it was conformist or not I mean
it was unquestionably a society that
demanded an incredible degree of control
ISM and it's much easier to figure out
who a nonconformist is or who's breaking
the rules when the rules are really
clear what happens twenty years later
when we have a full-blown market economy
entertainment culture we could even
argue that one of the most understudied
aspects of what's happening in Russia
today is the extent to which intent
entertainment culture you know of the
sort that fascist societies like because
it distracts from culture from politics
and this distracts people from looking
at politics is being encouraged in this
at the end that raiders the traditional
role of the russian writer as being a
spokesperson for society or how that you
know being a moral voice has been very
much sidetracked and that in fact again
i to come back to what this competition
might suggest is that a certain part of
the avant-garde is accepting this is the
normal place of the writer in the
society the normal place of the writer
of the great writer or the the the elite
writer is is to not write for an acyl
do not change politics to just right you
know and not to compete with detective
novels or not you know not to compete
with fortune then it's okay for all of
that to exist but it's very different
from the role that was the writers group
in terms of sometimes it just makes it
easier for presentations to lump and you
know the writers that of course straddle
several generations in terms
it's always funny me Scientology's that
begin with you know the show and then
with Zidane and this consider one
generation so it's always a problematic
but I think what we can say is that in
post-soviet in enough from the 1990s on
it wasn't only about their bring being
introduced to the underground culture of
the 70s and 80s but also you know the
20s
and all sorts of translations now being
accessible so that's why it was such an
exciting period so there was a
coexistence of various things not just
this generation but my argument today
was that this 70s generation was very
influential on providing a means of
existence and in production with a
survival kind of as an artist in the
situation that would come in post-soviet
times but so then you know you have
subsequent generations that are all a
part of this process now but that's
where the break is more important I
believe and just going back to this kind
of links wanted the answer to that was
that the fear of losing you know the
fear of the new this was exactly what
you crane that archer needed in 90s and
that's why it was so vibrant you know
there was various styles so there wasn't
a fear there was there was the 40 yeah
it was not stifling it was inspiring I
understand that country has one question
and then you know it's offer in terms of
legacies of descent it's it's been said
about specifically Russian literature or
Russian command conformists arianna of
the 1960s that went that left dr.
Zhivago the last part of the novel dr.
Zhivago in Yiddish Arago drops out of
Soviet society because there's no place
for them as a role model and so and so
deliberately intellectual figures would
take jobs as water Nakia you know where
or as janitors you know because that way
they would not be forced to compromise
their principles but also they they
actually identified this as being the
influence specifically of pus Rock's
novice so I don't know if you've seen
anything of that and then I had a I'm
gonna take this opportunity I'm not sure
this is kind of a question but but yes
since we're talking about legacies you
you brought
Russian culture just briefly on the
second interesting cause Ukrainian
television throwing the same films of
Russian classics all the time I can get
and goggle but you know so the
Ukrainians is present on Ukrainian TV
there as far as to Doctor Zhivago I
can't answer me maybe the panel the next
panel can say that but as far as jobs
working you know it's porters or
something I think it was you know you
had to have a job in the Soviet Union
you were thrown out of the the higher
education system and it often offered a
certain sense of freedom to create you
weren't really tied down to a certain
job so I think maybe that would be why
that would be
tract is hard to call attractive but
that was undertaken but maybe we'll ask
them that quickly I guess I think that
captain is a special case for a number
of reasons I mean if we look at Vytas
own career
it's interesting you know that
essentially his entire film career is
defined by commemorative art pieces
right I mean he's start one of his first
major pieces is Connor and Connor was a
commemoration of World War two it's a
form of world war two memory and 50 some
years later we get another form without
the obvious difference in political
valence so I don't know if it's possible
oh I know if it's possible to
extrapolate too much although I do think
it's interesting that particularly when
you compare the film medium to the
literary medium and even the theatrical
medium in Poland in terms of
representations I mean I hate to fixate
on World War two but that is sort of
where the the it's the focal point of
the commemorative action since 1989 you
know I mean just as one example young
too much grosses neighbors has produced
a number of works the the excuse me the
the Nika prize last year went to a book
the name is the skin of masha casa right
so our class which is a theatrical piece
based on playing out the fact pattern
for the above-named Massacre so there's
a real almost a direct correlation
between debates that are take place on
the boundaries of academic and public
media discussion and then the the art
that takes those as a springboard for
creating new valence as a memory it's
very interesting and there you can see
in Poland it's particularly for the past
decade there's real back and forth and
give-and-take between the death this is
in two different realms my question
principally I think would be to cut in
Upanishad she mentioned stylistic
difference of synapse T that's when my
question took us in upon me about
synapse key in context is stylistic
disagreement we
and even in that anyone could practice
descent in Russia as a political
prisoner trial and co-op sting you when
she mentioned you were correct that he
was stylistic different you know was
that the same I would say even though
Solzhenitsyn regardless of his confirm
means and going this stage being you
elite and accepting them just because of
his religious belief essential
and he you know agrees now with the
system of thinking which I myself
disagree in reference to your question
about church in the yesterday's panel
which is different issue and it might be
dressed in that panel but my question to
look at really how you would you know
balance that the words News ABC memories
yes what what the mist is she or
whatever you know it's not a dissident
trio no one it could imperil didn't
wasn't happy versus what regardless that
she might career on this you know the
dissident worgen and relations with the
west picture i'm gonna give you a copy
in my book which i should be it's a
really big question and i to be honest i
don't want to get hung up over
terminology because i don't have any
strong feelings personally I agree with
you we know who was who and and you know
who stepped I do agree with there was a
line people stepped over and once you
stepped over that line whatever you
called that person whether they were
dissident or a prisoner of conscience
there was a line and it's been well
documented in memoirs in people's life
stories that that that that there was a
point miss which you did you know that
you were you had you had parted company
with being an official Soviet citizen
and you are in some sense for lack of a
better term a dissident and I guess what
I'm trying to talk about the best the
best way I can think of in some short
way talking about this would be to refer
to the very end of a book Alma I'm here
I'm gonna ask a question and nobody has
to answer that has anybody in this
audience read under a Sanyasi steamy
goggle yeah yes okay so there are people
have read it I mean which which is one
of the great
unappreciated works of Russian
literature it ends when he talks about
the model of the sku model this
commodity who were who were engaged in
divine play and to in some sense
liberated thought and also represented
for him a meeting of spirituality and
play that was in some sense profoundly
liberating and to my mind that was his
model throughout his career for the way
he wrote it wasn't about having a
political program it was it was about
being free to to play in in a very for
him was a deeply religious sense and
that's one of the things that has not
been appreciate about Sinofsky organize
things
and I think very great contribution
thank you